hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing now
it seems according to you guys that it's
a very very bad idea
like the worst idea I could possibly
have so unbelievably bad idea to take
this goblet for some unknown reason
nobody could give me a straight answer
as to what it goddamn did so I'm gonna
assume that taking it it's gonna be bad
and destroying it is probably good but
you know I like this is like the Hat
situation where I kinda have to you know
it's a blood filled goblet but am I not
gonna take that with me how am I gonna
resist that good you know there's no
save mechanic in this game it's all like
continuously safe so no matter what I do
I can't save and go back if I wanted to
go back I'd have to play through it
again so I'm it's goddamn goblet I hear
y'all screaming oh and I can hear you
also screaming yes but I'm gonna take it
alright a chill runs down your spine as
you touch the Goblet yeah I stuck my
hand in too many of spittoons but this
gets my blood going there's a goblet of
blood from a cursed altar in a spooky
secret basement room
it's probably safe and fine and good hey
who's that oh it's by sorting by ordered
uh what's a smoking chrysanthemum I
don't need that
alright well I took it didn't seem to do
a lot maybe I gotta take it up to lady
here the door oh hey how's it going my
tea we can pitcher D party right now
and I know if I wanted to do this but
sure why not you carefully pour the
button from the Goblet into Grace's
mouth his litter box laughing maniacally
climbs the ranch houses drew and chimney
she turns towards you see you soon she
leaps to the ground mind the house and
scampers off to the northwest that's
[Laughter]
that's probably well my work here is
done
to the northwest view say to the
northwest dish somewhere up there let's
see if I can wander around and maybe
I'll find the shaggy-dog cave oh that's
not where I wanted to go but okay I
guess we're going there right now oh god
I don't have foraging hey how's it going
there what's up Oh Oh Gary knowing a
thing to see oh yeah what is it
a gigantic poop what taller than Gary
you discovered a new map location the
Big Apple okay all right then thanks for
the reminder I'll see you around Gary I
gotta go over here and explore see if
there's anything good to see all righty
then hello Oh many signs many words if
Gary could read in human so many words
would reading hear what they say guess
I'll find out okay flack is bolted to
the cave wall read it record of the
events of expedition 2 and into shaggy
dog cave as recorded by Jim plaque right
all right let me slap it over to the
next one all right having acquired
through various and sundry means a story
which is interesting in its own right
but better safer another time a map
pervading the VT lead to a large cache
of jewels in ingots of precious metals
hidden by the infamous highway and train
man train robber black coal junior in
the years before the cows came home I
Jim plaque right along with three
compatriots these being Nathaniel wine
and Cyrus Howard and Douglas watts
set out to find shaggy dog cave and the
aforementioned treasure okay
what about bad our equipment and
provisions consisted of one cart and a
to pull at for additional horses to be
written to shovels spade in a mining Pig
a large coil rope one large basket of
the eggs as well as an assortment of
other trail provisions cookware my own
collection two blank plaques engraving
tools one large and shaggy-dog and a
butt fern don't ask me what a bunch
what's a butt fern you're traveling for
two and a half days to the south and
east we arrived at a small town of dirt
water the largest settlement in the
vicinity of shaggy-dog came leaving the
local dog to watch the horses the four
of us entered the local saloon and each
ordered appear except for see who was
satisfied with water alrighty then we
have a good pair Department provided our
drinks as requested and withdrew a small
wooden box underneath the bar asking us
if we care to witness something real
interesting considering that we had
still in quite a few hours left to
travel we politely declined and asked
him if he knew the way to shaggy-dog
Cape York lied that he would never been
there personally but gave us rough
directions which correlated nicely with
the notes on our map okay and upon
leaving the saloon we discovered to our
dismay that some unknown villain
tampered with our racket unfortunately
the only supplies missing were the but
for an entire basket of eggs apart from
one but Doug had concealed within a
pocket for safekeeping we also
discovered that the dog and absconded
with one of horses forcing natan sigh
after dog lots to share after acquiring
a barrel of fresh water for the trip as
well as a replacement but for if we get
this out into the open desert the Sun
shone down mercilessly upon us though we
took some solace in the fact that I
would have been far more intolerable
have we maybe sex position during the
summer months rather than November in
order to pass it on on the trip and
resist becoming desert Mirage which
hours of soil
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a troll this is a troll game it's
all a completely empty one there was no
point in any of this what's a butt for
I'm on a ride my lamp back but a sail on
the sandy seas of the interior of this
goddamn cave oh my god how much did I
just read how much of my life did I just
waste there that I could have been doing
anything how will this moment in this
cave robbed me from some precious memory
I'll never know in my future
[Music]
there was no pointed any of that
McKittrick store where's McKittrick
store oh boy where am I going
McKittrick store cavern canyon were
supposed to go back it reeks
oh oh I got to go to it ah okay well
this is to the northwest let me go to
cavern candy and see if anything's up
there you encounter an overturned Wacken
all right convinced oh it rains
Cal punching I like me advanced
cow-punching can I get some of that I
get some of that let's see I can get
menacing mu a skill reduces muscle bull
stomp small anion to damage
ever-vigilant
increases your maximum ap by two I'm
gonna get that one that's good then you
shoot the book in two pieces because you
don't trust it the book had it coming it
did indeed it did indeed hey what does
the sign say that one it says danger
spider danger spider okay good luck to
you gary is to staying here for the
horses all right well it's babyish of
you pry off the boards those boards
can't hide from your prying eyes or your
pry bar oh I wish I had to get in the
coffee cactus so what's with all these
caves I'm gonna go in the one I just
pried danger spider
Doris like 15 dead bolts on it the note
tacked - it says please don't open this
door unless you want to get eaten by a
giant spider even then don't open it
because the rest of us don't want to get
eaten by a spider
it isn't even signed so you're gonna
hardly be expected to take it seriously
right here we go the tunnel behind this
open and goes straight up there's no way
to get through unless you're a huge
spider well I guess I shouldn't have
opened that door then oops my bad oh
what's this in Oh
hideout cave you can see the gang maybe
if you add more legs you'd be able to
pick your way through oh well
maybe I shouldn't worry about the
goddamn spider then ow well then what's
that hmm the bones make you pretty
reluctant to investigate this oh madness
son all right I got lit down on them you
said you're a sudden chittering coming
from the big hole behind you huh that's
peculiar
you must have a death wish let's close
to that thing not really you should
leave right now before that spider eats
you I don't know about that leave well
that was bad no where are you going back
in there
I don't know kind of want to go back in
there can I go back in there I guess you
could only get one thing out of that you
hear a horrible skittering noise
followed by a scream followed by more
horrible skittering noises followed by
more screams followed by some rapping
noises followed by some muffled screams
there's there's more skittering than
silence nobody go inside what's up how's
it going the gang has been prepped for
spider consumption anything just yet let
me see this hang on let me see what's
going on they're doodling good to do
danger kitchen danger
what's in the danger bar huh it looks
like this place needs a new bartender
what's this oh I got a jaw harp maybe
they killed him for playing the jaw harp
too much okay all right well all these
bottles are empty
putting bin air what's in the danger
kitchen oh hi whoa what are you doing
the poor chef has chained to the wall
his eyes widen as you approach hey
you're not one of them are you here to
rescue me sure well thank goodness he
thrust his hand into yours and shakes
vigorously I'm Doug
mum Fleur how do you do Doug well I've
been chained up in this dank cave for
weeks
cooking for those stripy tatted idiots
sounds awful you wonder the worst part
this is perfectly good oven eight feet
to my right and the Shelf of perfectly
good ingredients eight feet to my left
how's that the worst part Shan is only
four feet long that's rough I know right
there I was fresh out of culinary school
with a million meat ideas in my head and
now Here I am four feet shy my dreams
cooking the same pot of soup over and
over again
what million meat idea you uh you
promise not to steal my idea right yeah
I promise
okay then it's a new kind of sandwich or
maybe a taco it's so revolutionary then
I'm not quite sure how it fits in the
whole hand food taxonomy to be honest
anyway in the middle of it there's a
sausage but it's sauce is made from the
cheapest possible parts of a pig ground
up so finely you can't identify them
anymore okay and it's served in a long
split role which soaks up the grease so
you can't tell how fatty the sausage is
the best part the name you're ready to
hear the name sure I call it the hot dog
what do you think how about the hot mom
Fleur instead
don't be ridiculous hot mom Fleur what
does that even mean
ridiculous hey there's no need to be
mean about it not that any of this
matters anymore even if I did get off
this chain there's no point in hanging
around this empty cave making hot dogs
just for myself I don't even like the
taste of them instead of shopping dirt
water brilliant you're a genius mum
Fleur hot dogs for sale all day every
day I'll make a mint so here's an idea
what if I added mint to the sausage
mixture yup and breakers James he leaves
the cave hauling the oven and a shelf of
ingredients muttering to himself about
new sausage recipes well alright then
too bad about that I guess we're all
done here
hey guys what's going on here I'll
arrest them
maybe sure you stack the cocoons on the
back of your horse except for one which
Gary efforts to drag and head back to
the dirt water Jail is that the stripy
at gig what happened to him
they had a run-in with a giant spider a
giant spider of justice fortunately the
roar'd is for results rather than
explanations groovy because they're just
gonna be like that just wanted to say hi
hello alright I'm gonna go back now I
got work to do in that Canyon oh yeah
travel never mind
you find a wrecked bank stagecoach was
Astro
get open hey that's a good amount of me
I'll like that me that's good meat right
there let's see if the spiders still
there no uh spiders still there what's
this cave all about then what's all this
then huh oh this [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
all right
all right well if it's [ __ ] then
we're gonna get out here what's button
William's door probably probably fine
you see a streak of fire blasts across
the sky
all right that's a lot of meat a lot of
meat how did I get so much meat all
right I'm gonna do some shopping you
need anything trail mix no thanking you
Gary is good and well okay then ow ow
freaking out hello first you're excited
because you think this barrel is full of
pickles but they turn out to be novel
the rubber pickles huh all right
the woman behind the counter stares at
you with a huge grin on her face all
right what do you got oh I could always
use more shroom grow yeah anything else
here mind your meat this book is a guide
to making the most of your meat by
getting the best possible deal on every
single thing you buy gives me dickering
I can afford that
I want dick Curran oh god yes I've been
looking for dicker in mind your Mead you
read the book from cover to cover and
learn among other things that its cover
price is way too high well damn it all
right after you're done reading it you
use your newfound skills to pawn it off
on a wide-eyed rube for about 60 meet
done and done all right okay all right
well then how much can I sell anything
for nothing at all all right I know just
sell this is a certificate entitling the
bearer 213 shares of standard footwear
company a company based in Topeka just
sell it all right okay we'll do it all
right all right I'm out here baby
all that air in my weird way that I am
is out of here all right so let me
wander a bit more there's got to be
something else here right I don't know
where that doll went you lettering the
Dave yard
I'll go the Dave yard oh is that where
the doll went seems like it might be
where the doll went mmm
here lies Dave be died with his boots on
but not his pants
oh man after my own heart this is sure
enough you dig up the grave just to
check the veracity of the epitaph sure
enough boots but no pants brown boots
all right I got brown boots what does
that do for me maximum ap hell yeah
also I probably should do something
about this
still got that gobble of the blood which
is nice I guess
grits all right okay that uh-huh
you eat the grits Oh reminds me of
breakfast back home it gives you a real
hominy feeling uh-huh okay this is made
of goat milk extracted from plump utters
Oh plum pudding great eat that you eat
the pudding even though you haven't
eaten your meat no dark sarcasm here all
right okay that's weird
okay here we go the remains look pretty
Restless put him down for good all right
what do you got for me I don't want a
poison shoot you because I can bang get
some stench damage barely Hey oh my god
are you too strong skull tips gold tooth
your lives Dave see went down in a
theater your lives Dave Jay wrap up a
POW see I'll put you down yeah oh you
guys are just big old babies I'm not
even gonna need to muscle up for you
we're just gonna attack you good and
you're gonna be dead oh no you're gone
okay skeleton bone dude your lives Dave
L died of a heart attack
oh that's why it's the Dave yard it's a
graveyard full of Dave's it's you and
negative 36 years
your lives Dave G looking to the sky to
save him but even the sky can't save a
fellow from Blake forty angry bears ah
looks like the gravedigger left his
lunchbox here oh boy free lunch
Vienna blood sausages thermos of spiked
coffee and they said there was no such
thing ah I guess that's good Vienna
blood sausages I'll leave them oh yeah
you can't eat that cuz you're already
too full level up your grit to increase
your appetite
alright these bones are jumping around
to the beat of the Dickens it beat the
Dickens beat the tickets I'll beat the
Dickens Eddie whoa oh yeah you don't get
most spooky damage to me I'm too tough
for you I'm legitimately too tough for
anybody here Oh
skeleton bones what else we got here
before we go in there Dave D the truth
was out there it killed him Dave G
murdered by a different feller named
Dave G pile of bones that isn't moving
around for a change dig through it oh I
got a skull with an odd tag on it
alright what does that mean
let's see inter cemetery lone on one
side and some notes on the other tag on
the skull as a serial number and says it
was borrowed from the submission
catacombs On February 19 to 1886 Jesus
really laid the back of the tag is
catacombs address old mission skulls
check him out all right okay glue later
hello anybody in here anybody at all
it's one of those things they have in
mausoleums you know it's one of those
big marble things full of drawers full
of skeletons hope I'm going to open a
whole bunch of them I'm gonna open a
whole bunch now
[Music]
okay all right then I'm gonna this might
actually be a bit of a bit of a scuffle
here but a muscle-up gonna hit you real
good Oh whoop oh you're dead oh no all
right
hey you hi-yah style yeah all right
you're almost dead yeah all right got
that easy peasy
was that just is that just a way to farm
some fights that's pretty convenient oh
this looks bad drawn on the ground with
red chalk pile of mostly burned rags
that maybe used to be a person great
Gore splattered scroll human ashes Road
receipt right why what is this
150 black ropes it's time we start
gathering clues about the whole
perambulating dead situation that's
going on around these parts you grab a
notebook and paper clip the receipt to
the first page got a necromancer journal
I should check that out all right
you hope your neck and your necromancer
journal and examine the information you
collected so far
you found a receipt for delivery of
robes looking at it more closely you see
there's a surcharge for delivery to
Boulder pass that means the necromancer
layer is definitely west of the
mountains know what else I got gore
splattered scroll great scrape the
largest of the giblets off the scroll
and read it says to take a pile of human
ashes spread them around in the shape of
a person inside a Red Rock ritual circle
then sprinkled them with Stardust and
placed a Mosely perfect or better glass
sphere where the heart should be anyway
that suggests of it the actual text says
a lot more these in thousands such as
like that plus there's a weird a bit of
weird gibberish you're supposed to say
out loud while you're doing it okay good
to know
great all right it's the cremated ashes
remains of a person someday they'll
refer to these as cremains but you will
not approve Oh leave them alone for now
maybe I should scatter them or somewhere
a little bit better Oh perform the
ritual
oh I don't need glass spheres okay all
right
I don't even know if I have Stardust but
okay all right whatever
all right so apparently that little girl
ain't here let's wander a bit more a
skeleton approach you turn that jittery
stop-motion II way that skeletons dude
judging by its had it appears to be the
skeleton of a bean slinger you remember
the classic saying old bean singers died
like normal people but sometimes they
keep walking around in casting spells
afterwards okay Wow
all right well I got bean stain pants I
don't know what that means but I got him
snake pit mine that's a new one what's
this an exposed meat vein that sounds
horribly like a vagina Oh a digging hole
much quite big much a lot of digging
must be do goblins mine for metal some
not much not like humans digging it all
up but metal is full of many uses
hitting with hammer making better hammer
sure okay all right look at mining
equipment you have no idea what any of
it does ask Gary to explain it to you
hey how does this work
oh oh no no Gary doesn't knowing that
thank you Gary
Gary you know what this did no okay all
right
how about this one Gary Gary no okay all
right then well I'll just be on my way
all right wish I had foraging but I
don't hello by the loose boards okay
snake coiled up in a little hole pull it
punch it do I have two against me great
snakes in this smoking hole smoking
snake cash mining supplies all right
well got those
all right got a pickaxe all right that's
good maybe I can use it on oh wow that
was horrible
come on I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
these snake eggs whoo is there any way I
can hit all of them probably not this
seems like really mean to just kind of
beat up these eggs y'all hit him this
seems just seems bad oh oh okay I get it
now
they were always bad I was just doing
doing him a favor that's what I was
doing oh no Gary your son died what are
you gonna do
oh nothing okay all right oh wait I
forgot about my a varmint skinning knife
wait wait wait wait wait wait yeah cuz I
want the skins of the beasts all right
you smoked and snake poison you because
there was no point cuz you're about to
die all right okay all done here well
that was productive and I'm a horse
apparently well at least check out a
pickaxe which is gonna be useful in the
future I can only imagine what else we
got
whoa I can use my cow punching ability
I'm gonna get beefy for you cuz you need
to get beefed why am i buying point whoa
okay wow that wasn't a lot of damage how
about some stench Oh No tainted milk
don't know if I want that milk but I got
extra thick leather which is nice I
where else can we go railroad camp old
mission baby - baby - boo boo do cuz
it's always possible that the doll went
beyond the mountains and that's probably
something that's very important to
understand but I'm gonna go to Fort
cowardice first just to see how that
goes 300 yards away solitary skeleton
I'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of it Wow
all right arriving oh that's going mmm
this fort quite very quiet being I
thought goblins here just sound a bandit
might as well have a look okay
just like the old saying goes when life
give you cannons makes make cannonade
that was bad see hey hey hey hey goblins
goblins here somewhere really how can
you tell how you can't uh well let you
know if I find any I suppose climb up
the watchtower and take a look around
nice view up here Oh
Butterfield ranch oh that's nice am I
going here any goblins in there I heard
that there might be goblins here they're
incredibly boring no I really want the
details you find one you read becky
smith secretary grade satified another
you find one major Ezra wolf another
another another another another another
another whoa now you're just looking at
the same ones you've read before well
this is wrong with you I can't get
enough oh these are good these are good
oh I love them
all these are good all right well
thought there would be some kind of
reward for this I don't know why I
fought that but I fought it okay
reception desk a most appropriate thing
for it to receive would it be a free
trip to the dump food Oh military-grade
whiskey I don't know what that means
cupboard spice rack saltpeter I got that
saltpeter that the guy wanted well I
don't know what that means for me here
ah knot of needles but what else do I
have in here I've got a whole bunch of
[ __ ] don't I oh I need to spend my exp
oh [ __ ] I've got so much exp well I need
more glamour and gumption
that's it definitely
whoo that yep okay how about some of the
beefed up first aid okay got it
all right well goody-goody good for me
I'll get another needle and I'll come
back here for that one that's all wait
this is exactly what I was just in
goblin whoo you hear the sound of
several goblins storing inside the stent
not bothering let them sleep okay all
right then hello cot is soaked with
blood great based on the papers and
anatomical diagram scattered across its
surface you're getting to this Ford desk
belong to the fort cowardice is nurse
look at the papers papers are mostly
just boring medical records Dental
dagger rule tapes lamentations that
antibiotics haven't been discovered yet
that kind of thing hey what's this looks
like it might be important marching
orders oh they're just a bunch of
disgusting drawings of sliced open
bodies but I did get marching orders
what does that mean March back east just
as fast as you live the liver
lily-livered little yellow-bellied feet
can go your damnable cowards right then
they went to Fort all dead treacherous
territory up there
a feller ought to be careful they went
to all dead I love that I love that
you're the fort all dead sign says
toilet in goblin which makes it seem
pretty likely that goblins uses 10 as a
toilet no where are you going in there
wait no I want to go in there oh I want
to go in there yikes this mishap
definitely got somebody fired see the
unusually sized cannonball
you got a Dem I culverin cannonball why
did I pick that up no damn I less know
Demi Moore oh I get it that's funny all
right I'm gonna force my way over here
well why can't we wake up the goddamn
goblins what can't we wake up the
goblins I guess I got to pick that lock
don't I I don't have one I can go buy
some can't I let me go back to town
doodlee do you got to go to the
mercantile hey you got any uh picking
locks no you don't you don't I'll buy
this book off yeah but you don't do
even though I got the dickering ability
all right thick-skinned ooh
armored bull stomp haymaker Oh oh hell
yeah
oh I want the haymaker I want to be
swinging my haymakers around Oh witch
away so I could be smacking cows in
their goddamn face perfect okay so
that's good I don't think I have any
letters would I nope okay all right then
so I think that's gonna do it for this
episode thank you everybody
Oh hot dog man hot dog howdy Doug well
if it isn't my shave your good old mum
Fleur howdy yourself
the sign outside yeah I had to change
the name I tried to file a trademark and
it turns out there's already something
called a hot dog
what is it trust me you want to know I
wish I didn't know anyway a single
letter removed and I'm in business he
gestures at the menu behind the wall all
right I'll buy I'll buy a nice jumbo
deal look a fixture tea hot dog for a
fig sturdy cowboy this hot dog has been
embellished with the zesty thoth don't
get too excited though it's the zesty
sauces just regular old mustard this is
exactly enough sausage and exactly
enough bun to qualify as a hot dog
it is perfectly efficient all right I'll
take the big one to pickin I don't know
if I can eat it is my gumption enough oh
my grits not enough ooh maybe I can get
it all right now I know I can eat that
hot dog
hell yeah get it in me what oh you sack
of [ __ ] anyway all right that's enough
for that this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm
enjoying the heck out of this hope you
are too so let me know what do you think
down the comments below and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]